Herzlich Willkommen zum Chaosradio 281. In schöner Regelmäßigkeit senden wir ja gerade wieder, dank gewisser Dinge, die passiert sind. Wir wechseln uns gerade mit den dicken Brettern ab. Da ging es in der letzten Folge um hervorragender Blackout gleich zu Beginn der Sendung.
Chat-Kontrolle, Hanni.
Chat-Kontrolle. Und heute geht es hier im Chaosradio der Sendung, die aus der Perspektive und mit anverwandten befreundeten ExpertInnen immer technische Probleme und gesellschaftliche Auswirkungen erklärt, um ein fliegendes Pferd, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, und um ein Thema, das so alt wie die Sendung selbst stimmt nicht, aber Staatstrojaner hat man vielleicht das ein oder andere Mal schon gehört. Dazu begrüßen wir recht herzlich Ilf. Hallo, guten Tag. Hallo. Rainer? Hallihallo. Ilf kennt man von... Ilf, woher kennt man dich?
Aus dem CCILF kennt man aus dem CCC und netzaktivistischen Umtrieben.
Kommen wir gleich zu.
Wir haben alle andere Forderungen. Keine Frage. Aber ich denke schon, dass es wichtig ist, dass die formuliert haben, was Standard sein müssten. Natürlich können sie niemanden dazu bringen, die zu bestießen. Europa hat diese Macht tatsächlich nicht. Aber das mal aufzuzählen, zu sagen, hör mal zu, gegen diese, diese Standards habt ihr verstoßen. Und die stellen wir erstmal auf, diese Standards. Die sind notwendig, wenn ihr das überhaupt einsetzt. Das finde ich erstmal nicht falsch. Und ich finde auch das EU Tech Lab nicht falsch. Denn das soll ja unter anderem auch eine forensische Analyse liefern. Also du kannst tatsächlich mit der Hardware hingehen. Wahrscheinlich werden sie die Vorarbeit von anderen nutzen. Aber sei es drum, dann kannst du dir sozusagen einen forensischen Beweis geben lassen. Für zum Beispiel eine Spionagesoftware. Ich halte das schon nicht für unwichtig.
Also der Unterschied, den ich gerade bemerke, ist sozusagen, du glaubst an das politische System. Und du bist eher skeptisch. Was sind dir beides verliehende Perspektiven?
Naja, also dieses Tech Lab, so wie ich es verstanden habe, ist ja auch so nach dem Vorbild von dem Citizen Lab, das ist ja Uni Toronto gemacht. Und es ist natürlich schön, da jetzt irgendwie Hardware hinzugeben und auch diese Art von Forschung selber zu machen. Auch empirisch kann man ja auch viel skalierend, wenn man sich auch dann mit so einem Lab mit den anderen Ländern zusammenschließt. Da gibt es ja auch, man kann ja auch Allianzenbildung machen und so weiter. Ich glaube, der Unterschied zwischen den beiden Extremen ist so, dass Ilfald sagt, naja, mehr wär viel cooler gewesen. Aber wenn man überlegt, was so ein Ausschuss überhaupt leisten kann, dann ist er da auch ziemlich dolle herangekommen an das, was er leisten kann. Nämlich zu sagen, guck mal, das läuft alles total schief.
Aber das hört sich schon ein bisschen an so im Rahmen seiner Möglichkeit bestens bemüht.
Also das würde ich jetzt auch hier unterschreiben. Also das ist nie wieder mal so.
Naja, aber das ist ja sozusagen, wie viel das EU-Parlament machen kann oder nicht. Das hat ja nichts mit Pegasus zu tun. Das ist ja eine EU-Architekturfehler. So meine ich das.
Aber da ist gerade ein Punkt, der ist mir noch entgangen, weil ihr habt es am Anfang ja gesagt und dann hatten wir auch noch ein anderes konkretes Beispiel. Wir haben jetzt immer über Pegasus geredet, aber der Untersuchungsausschuss sollte ja auch ähnliche Dinge, was ist da noch rausgekommen? Wie viele Firmen gibt es? Haben wir in Deutschland eine multiple Anzahl von verschiedenen Staatstrojanern? Oder war es dann letztlich doch so?
Na die haben sich dafür diesen sogenannten Global Spy Index nochmal erklären lassen. Es gibt ja auch eine bisschen systematische Forschung darüber, wie viele Anbieter gibt es. Das machen verschiedene NGOs, die die zusammentragen. Und Forscher, die sich auf den Messen umsehen, die führen so eine öffentliche Raw-Data-Liste. Und da wird einmal eingetragen, was international berichtet wird. Also wir reden so ein bisschen über 75 Länder sind da jetzt drauf. Und da sind auch die Anbieter benannt, so was sie noch gibt. Es gibt ja häufig auch Umbenennungen und Neugründungen und so. Also die versuchen ein bisschen diesen Markt zu tracken. Aber es gibt natürlich auch noch die Art, wird das heitige Aufheben sehr wichtig, die tatsächlichen ausgenutzten Exploits anzusehen. Also welche Betriebssysteme werden angegriffen, mit welchen Methoden. Also die technische Ebene gibt es auch noch.
Also ich würde noch konkret ergänzen, ja, es gibt mehrere Dutzend Hersteller und Produkte für Staatstrojaner da draußen und die Untersuchungsausschuss in Europa hat sich neben Pegasus vor allem ein Produkt namens Predator angeguckt, das vor allem in Griechenland extrem viel gefunden wird. Die haben aber auch mit Augen an Finfischer aus Deutschland, Candiru auch aus Israel, ähnliche Produkte angeguckt. Leider war der Hauptfokus aber meistens auf NSO und Pegasus, weil das ja auch im Ausschuss des Namens und im Ausschuss des Pegasusprojekts so prominent war und weil er auch einer der derzeit großen und mächtigen und weit verbreiteten Tools ist. Ist aber bei weitem nicht der einzige. In Deutschland hat das BKA zum Beispiel einen eigenen Trojaner programmiert. Also es gibt mehrere Trojaner, die Staaten besitzen. Auch Deutschland hat mehr als drei Staatstrojaner in petto, die sie einsetzen können.
Es liegt natürlich ein bisschen daran, muss man jetzt auch mal sagen. Also die NSO hat da wen hingeschickt. Natürlich war das sozusagen so eine Art lebender Chat-GPT oder so. Also ich meine, er hat sich ja auch sehr stark wiederholt und so. Aber die haben da wen hingeschickt und keinen anderen Vertreter gehabt. Also wenn ich jetzt in die Branche hier stetig eingegeben hätte. Predator ist deswegen interessant, weil dort auch kommerzielle Firmen, die meistens Software machen, um so Spionagesoftware abzuwehren. Da gibt es schon einen großen Bericht von Talos etwa. Also die haben da auch eine gute technische Analyse. Wenn man die hat, dann kann man auch darüber sprechen. So ähnlich bei dem Wiener-Anbieter, den Ilf vorhin schon ansprach. Die sind ja nicht mehr am Markt offenbar. Die haben sich aus Wien wieder verabschiedet. Aber da waren einige Unterlagen aus dem Unternehmen und auch technische Unterlagen abhanden gekommen. Das kann man sich dann mal ansehen.
Also falls ihr gerade diesen Podcast hört und bei einem Trojaner-Hersteller arbeitet.
Achso, der CCC nimmt weiterhin Samples entgegen. Weiterhin sehr gern. Jetzt wäre ein guter Zeitpunkt. Immer ist ein guter Zeitpunkt.
Was sind denn jetzt sozusagen, wir haben schon festgestellt, ihr habt diese Ergebnisse des Untersuchungsausschusses, haben ja eine verschiedene Bewertung, eine unterschiedliche Bewertung erfahren. Was sind jetzt eure Forderungen? Was hättet ihr denn gerne sagen, wie dieses Szenario in Zukunft behandelt wird?
Ich würde noch einen Satz voranschieben. Wir haben jetzt relativ viel gesagt, ob uns die Empfehlungen reichen oder nicht. Wir haben aber relativ wenig konkret gesagt, was sie denn jetzt sind. Ich würde es mal ein bisschen flapsig zusammenfassen, der Rest der EU sollte das ungefähr so machen wie in Deutschland. Also wirklich nur gegen Terroristen und wirklich nur gegen Kriminelle, nur mit Richterbeschluss und nur wenn die überwachten danach, damit darüber informiert werden. Und nur wenn es irgendeine Aufsicht darüber gibt, die auch funktioniert.
Ja, aber Verzeihung, das ist nicht nur die deutsche Gesetzgebung, sondern das ist auch die höchstrichterliche Rechtsprechung, die sie zu erfüllen haben. Das sind Minimalstandards.
In Deutschland, aber im Endeffekt sagt der EU-Abschlussbericht, bitte lieber andere 26 EU-Staaten, macht das ungefähr so auf dem Level wie Deutschland.
Sie haben auch ein paar Standards drin, die wir in Deutschland nicht erfüllen. Zum Beispiel, dass man eine ordentliche Prüfung vorab geben muss. Haben wir bei uns nicht. Die hat es nicht vorgeschrieben. Ein Risiko meinetwegen.
Die Prüfung vorab heißt, BKA wieder widersprechen, nämlich dass die Polizei sehr wohl eine Prüfung durchführt, die uns natürlich nicht genügt, ist korrekt.
Uwe, sie haben parlamentarische Protokolle gegeben und du hast da selber darüber geschrieben, dass die Anbieter den Quellkod nicht rausrücken und dass auch die Prüfbehörden den Quellkod nicht haben dürfen und dass wenn sie auch nur gucken wollen, erst mal eine Nutzungsgebühr zu zahlen ist. Also ich meine, come on, das ist in Deutschland nicht vorgeschrieben. Aber sie wollen halt eine sogenannte, nennen die glaube ich ex ante Prüfung, also eine Vorabprüfung und eine danach. Und da reicht nicht sozusagen eine Versicherung auf dem Papier. Aber sie wollen auch ein paar anderen Sachen, die wir nicht haben. Sie haben sehr viel stärkere Transparenzpflichten vorgeschrieben. Bei sozusagen bei der Nutzung von Staatsräumen und auch eine Transparenzpflicht für die Kontrollbehörden, die mit Verlaub bei uns nicht alle Kontrollbehörden haben. Transparenz gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit?
Oder gegenüber dem Parlament?
So genau steht es jetzt nicht drin. Aber überhaupt eine Transparenzpflicht wäre schon mal schön, oder? Na, warten!
Naja, das scheint mir dann wieder eine Feigenblatt-Forderung zu sein. Transparent müsste sein gegenüber dem, von wem dürfte ich das beantworten.
Nicht nur in der Märchenstunde vom PKGR.
Die Kontrollbehörden.
Das ist der Parlamentarische Untersuchungsausschuss.
Kontrollgremium.
Das ist das, was in Deutschland dafür zuständig ist, eigentlich die Geheimdienste zu kontrollieren.
Nee, ich wollte nur noch erweitern, dass diese Forderungen natürlich auch deswegen nicht reichen, weil es in Deutschland selbst nicht so der Fall ist, dass es nur gegen Terrorismus benutzt wird. Da wird so ein juristischer Knifte benutzt und gesagt, na guck mal, die Online-Durchsuchung machen wir nur gegen große Güter der Allgemeinheit und Terror und konkrete Anhaltspunkte. Und dann gibt es aber noch die Quellen-TKÜ. Das ist eigentlich genau das Gleiche wie der Staatstrojaner, aber der verspricht ganz hoch und heilig mit Ehrenwort, dass er nur auf Kommunikation zugreift. Und das wird halt nach Ruhe...
Das ist glaube ich, dass ich es immer kurz erklären muss. Quellen-TKÜ meint, es gibt Kommunikation, die kann man nicht mehr wie früher, kann sich nicht der Mann an die Telefonleitung abhören, weil das verschlüsselt ist und deswegen sagt man gut, wir hören das Gespräch ab, aber auf dem Gerät, wo es geführt wird. Und Gespräch ist dann manchmal auch ein Chat und das ist dann die Quellen-Telekommunikationsüberwachung.
Korrekt, genau das.
Wir haben sogar drei Rhianna in den deutschen gesetzt. Also wir haben die Online-Besuchung, die das volle Gerät durchsuchen darf. Und wir haben die Quellen-TKÜ, die jetzt reine Ansprache, also laufende Kommunikation abzuhören, unterschiedliche Art, Messenger oder Mail oder so. Aber wir haben auch noch die sogenannte Quellen-TKÜ Plus, die kann, ja, ich fand's eher, ja.
Das hört sich an wie so ein Ticket von der Bahn.
Ja, oder wie Waschpulver.
Manche sagen dazu, manche würden auch die kleine Online-Durchsuchung nennen, weil man nämlich dann etwas mehr darf. Man darf die laufende Kommunikation plus zum Beispiel auch zugreifen auf andere Dienstleistungen. Also das ist so ein Zwischenprojaner. Das ist aber auch, was jetzt aktuell gerade mit einer Verfassungsbeschwerde...
Genau, und um sozusagen abzuschließen, genau, was ich damit eben sagen wollte, wie Konstanze jetzt schön auch auch detailliert beschrieben hat, da wird halt juristisch ein Unterschied aufgemacht, der technisch überhaupt nicht existiert. Das heißt, zu sagen, macht es wie in Deutschland, bezieht sich nur auf das, was hier auch Online-Durchsuchung genannt wird. Und das andere, was unter falscher Flagge oder unter dem falschen Pferdeschwanz fährt, das müsste man eigentlich erst mal diskutieren. Aber ich wäre froh, wenn wir europäisch sozusagen das überhaupt so differenziert argumentieren würden.
Also ich meine, auch die Deutschen haben sich diese Quellenticker-Konstrukte ausgedacht. Ich meine, was für ein genialer Schachzug. Sie haben einfach einen Teil der Staatsstrojaner anders benannt und haben dafür andere Regeln. Und damit meine ich, mit Präupungsmittelgesetz und Urkunden fällt schon. Du darfst den Einsatz...
Hier möchte ich noch mal einen hacken. Die sogenannte Quellenticker-Telekommunikationsüberwachung, wo ein Staat heimlich in ein IT-Gerät eindringt, die Integrität bricht und abhört, aber in Ihren Worten, wir beschränken uns auf Laufenden der Telekommunikation, die ist überall möglich, wo auch ein normales Telefon abgehört wird. Das ist ein langer Katalog an 26 Straftaten. Aber es ist nicht so, dass eine Onlinedurchsuchung, wo alles abgehört werden kann, was auf dem Gerät ist, besonders viel weniger Einschränkungen hat. Die dürfen angeblich auch nur gegen besonders schwere Straftaten eingereicht werden. Diese Liste ist aber ähnlich lang. Und auch darunter fallen Dinge wie Verleitung zur missbräuchlichen Asylantragstellung, Steuerdelikte und so. Also es sind nicht nur die Dinge, an die wir so verdenken, nämlich Mord, Totschlag und Ähnliches, sondern sowohl die Quellen-TKÜ als auch die Online-Durchsuchung sind für eine ganze Reihe an legal definierten, schweren Straftaten bis hin zur Verleitung zur missbräuchlichen Asylantragstellung legal möglich in Deutschland heute.
Auch die Quellen-TKÜ Plus, die ich noch mal erinnern möchte. Wir vergessen immer den dritten schönen Trojaner. Also, ich meine, das eine ist, wir haben mehrfach angesprochen, wir reden darüber, dass wir unsere IT-Sicherheit generell jetzt gegen einen Markt verteidigen. Und so muss man finde ich auch an diesem Markt ran. Man muss diesen Markt ausdrücken. Und wie man das angeht, ist glaube ich nicht unbedingt nur eine deutsche Aufgabe, sondern auch eine europäische. Aber da ist für mich sozusagen the root of all evil. Denn gegen diese Mechanismen des Marktes zu kämpfen, der einfach auch wirklich ein Multimillionenmarkt geworden ist über die letzten zehn Jahre, ist sozusagen so ein bisschen der Ei des Kolumbus in dieser Sache. Und Europa spielt eine große Rolle als Käufer, aber auch als Exporteur. Also auch als potenter Käufer. Klar, da gibt man eine Menge Geld für aus. Und deshalb kann man da natürlich versuchen anzusetzen. Na ja, du kannst dir jetzt überlegen, was du tust. Also dann machst du bestimmte Dinge illegal, die nicht mehr verkauft oder exportiert werden können. Oder du setzt dabei an, wo die Sicherheitsblücken unter die konkreten Exploits gehandelt werden. Also mir geht es um diesen Markt. Und die Forderung, dass du...
Na ja, man kann ja zumindest erst mal sagen, dass man da selber erst mal nicht mitmacht. Also wenn wir sagen, wir sind halt irgendwie die westlichen und so weiter, in Anführungsstrichen, Staaten und so weiter, das ist ja genau die Begründung für alle anderen Staaten zu sagen, guck mal, die machen das auch nicht nur moralisch, sondern auch einfach mit Geld. Wenn die europäischen und US-Staaten diesen Markt nicht so befeuern würden, dann wäre der viel, viel kleiner. Das heißt, selber da nicht mitmachen ist sozusagen der Schritt hin zum Austrocknen und auch zur Delegitimierung. Und die zweite Forderung muss natürlich sein, mann genommen es gäbe diesen Markt jetzt nicht mehr und dann gibt es immer noch die selbstgebauten Trojaner von BND und so weiter, die jetzt nicht so viel können, aber trotzdem schlimm genug. Das muss natürlich auch trotzdem aufhören. Also dieses Instrument an sich, das muss natürlich komplett verboten werden, weil dieser Integritätsverlust, der ist sozusagen, das ist die entscheidende Hürde in den Geist des Menschen, in sozusagen die Externalisierung. Das heißt selbst, wenn wir die selbst gebaut nur hätten, wäre die zweite Forderung eben dann, dieses ganze Instrument abzuschaffen und auch zu schauen, es ist ja nicht das Ende des Abendlandes. Es gibt ja auch andere Möglichkeiten, Ermittlungen zu führen. Dieses Instrument hat so viele Kollateralschäden, auch insgesamt global, dass wir sowas überhaupt gar nicht einsetzen sollten.
Also ich würde das gerne noch ein bisschen konkreter machen. Erstmal bei dem Markt, noch mal zur Vergegenwertigung. Wir haben es hier mit Hacking zu tun, dem unbefugten Eindringen des Staates in IT-Geräte. Dazu nutzen sie meistens Sicherheitslücken aus. Und zwar Sicherheitslücken, die den Herstellern noch nicht bekannt sind, sonst gäbe es ja einen Patch dafür. Wir haben im Koalitionsvertrag stehen, dass der Staat keine Sicherheitslücken ausnutzt, sondern sie immer schnellstmöglich schließt. Das ist jetzt keine Forderung vom CCC, das ist Forderung der Bundesregierung.
Aber das wurde eine vom CCC.
Ja, das ist auch weiterhin eine Forderung des CCC und das ist auch richtig und logisch. Und die einzige wichtige Regelung, wie einer von 192 Nationalstaaten in dieser globalen Welt mit Sicherheitslücken umgehen sollte. Es kann doch nicht sein, dass wir Milliarden iPhones und Androids auf der ganzen Welt hackbar halten, nur damit die deutsche Polizei zwölf Drogendealer pro Jahr hackt. Das ist nämlich das, wo die das zurzeit einsetzen. Und da kommen wir dann nämlich auch zu dem Punkt, wo die spanische Regierung der Geheimdienst das gegen angebliche Separatisten in Katalonien einsetzt und gleichzeitig mit genau demselben Produkt, mit genau derselben Sicherheitslücke der marokkanische Geheimdienst den spanischen Staatspräsidenten hackt. Das kann doch nicht sein, dass wir unsere IT Gegenwart, die überall heraus erreichbar ist, per Internet für alle unsicher halten, damit wir einen minimalen öffentlichen Sicherheitsgewinn für ein paar polizeiliche Ermittlungen bekommen. Es dürfen niemals unbekannte Schwachstellen von Staaten ausgenutzt werden, sondern sie müssen immer schnellstmöglich geschlossen werden. Und da gibt es einen Markt da draußen, und der muss ausgetrocknet werden, indem zum Beispiel die Staaten selber mitkaufen und Sicherheitsforscherinnen belohnen, um diese Lücken für alle schließen zu können. Denn das ist ein bisschen wie bei Pandemien, niemand ist sicher, bis alle sicher sind. Das sind die Schwachstellen. Aber auch zu den Firmen gibt es weit mehr als wir sollten da nicht so viel mitspielen. In den USA gab es nach Pegasus-Project nicht nur Sanktionen, sondern vor ein paar Wochen hat das Weiße Haus eine neue Richtlinie herausgebracht. Und zwar ist es US-Behörden verboten, mit Firmen Geschäfte zu machen, die entweder die nationale Sicherheit der USA bedrohen, heißt deren Produkte könnten auch gegen US-Interessen eingesetzt werden. Konkretes Beispiel, Pegasus wurde in Uganda gegen US-Diplomaten eingesetzt, weswegen die USA gesagt haben, das heißt US-Behörden dürfen dieses Produkt nicht mehr kaufen.
Wir hatten eine US-Bürgerin im Ausschuss, die Facebook-Vertreterin war eine US-Bürgerin.
Das war auch noch eine US-Bürgerin. Das Weiße Haus sagt ganz klar, Produkte, die gegen die USA eingesetzt werden, dürfen von den USA nicht gekauft werden. Und sie gehen sogar noch weiter und sagen, Produkte, die in Diktaturen, von Diktaturen, zur Unterdrückung der kritischen Öffentlichkeit der Zivilgesellschaft eingesetzt werden, dürfen von US-Behörden nicht genutzt werden. Das ist aktive, sogenannte wertegeleitete Außenpolitik. Das ist das, mit dem die Grünen draußen hausieren können. Das sollten wir auch machen. Das ist jetzt auch keine Nischenforderung von irgendwelchen Radikalos auf der Straße. Das ist das fucking Weiße Haus. Warum kriegt es Deutschland und Europa nicht hin, diese beiden Dinge genauso zu gewinnen und sogar nach dem nächsten Schritt zu gehen? Nicht nur wir kaufen das nicht, sondern wir sanktionieren diese Firmen, die diese Tools produzieren und international verkaufen, wie eben NSO mit ihrem Pegasus, damit sie keine US-Produkte wie Android-Geräte, iOS-Geräte, Amazon Cloud und WhatsApp-Programme nutzen können. Was das Weiße Haus gerade jetzt tut?
Ich habe trotzdem eine Frage. Ich glaube, von allen Regierungen der Welt ist das Weiße Haus wahrscheinlich die, die das am wohlverhältnismachen kann, weil die wahrscheinlich die Ressourcen haben, das Inhouse zu lösen.
Europa ist doppelt so groß wie die USA. Er hat doppelt so viele Einwohner, eine größere Wirtschaftsleistung. Warum sollte Europa das nicht genauso gut können? Zumal das nicht auf meine nächsten Forderungen eingeht. Ich habe nämlich noch ein paar mehr.
Naja, also ich finde es schon erstaunlich, wie die USA, also Ilf hat das eben umschrieben, wie sie sich hinstellt. Aber natürlich muss man sehen, dass die Presse, die US-amerikanische Presse zumindest in zwei Fällen aufgedeckt hat, dass sie das selber hintergehen. Das liegt natürlich daran, dass die Geheimdienste dort Geheimverträge einfach machen. Und man mal Glück hat, wenn Journalisten die bekommen. Also da gibt es natürlich auch wieder, die haben eine offizielle Policy, aber die hintergehen sie auch selbst. Aber dennoch, das sind wichtige Zeichen. Das ist schon mal wichtig. Und das Zeichen hat Europa noch nicht hingekriegt.
Nicht nur können sie es nicht, die wollen es nicht. Die USA haben Pegasus sanktioniert und Deutschland ist trotzdem weiter Kunde. Deutschland besitzt jetzt in diesem Moment NSO, Pegasus und die Polizei kann das meinetwegen gegen die letzte Generation einsetzen. Und sie könnten genauso gut sagen, nein wollen wir nicht, weil das auch gegen unseren Kanzler oder unsere kritische Infrastruktur oder unsere sonst was eingesetzt werden könnte. Oder weil das von Diktatoren wie Saudi-Arabien und Mexiko zum Morden von Journalistinnen genutzt wird. Das wollen sie politisch nicht. Das könnten sie und sollten sie jetzt tun.
Und diese Verbote sind ja auch immer sehr national geleitet. Also bei USA, solange es noch Westbridge Technologies waren, die den Pegasus irgendwie Phantom genannt haben, war alles okay. Aber als das das erste Mal gegen US-Bürgerinnen benutzt wurde, da war es dann nicht mehr okay mit dem nicht wollen. Das finde ich tatsächlich auch sehr wichtig. Man könnte natürlich auch nicht nur Druck auf die Firmen machen, sondern gerade bei der NSO-Group ist es ja so, die sind ja in Israel und die sind ja auch gewollt. Und da kann man ja auch sozusagen mal mit Brüderstaaten, Schwesterstaaten sprechen, dass das vielleicht keine gute Idee ist. Hacking-Tee by die Italien, Finfischer war irgendwie Deutschland und Niederland oder so. Ist ja nicht so, dass die Hackerbuden alle Nordkorea sitzen oder so. Das ist gerade nicht so.
Also man könnte natürlich auch nochmal eine Ebene darüber denken. Man könnte sich natürlich schon auch hinscheiden und sagen, wir bräuchten auch mal eine ordentliche EU-Konvention, dass man über Digitalwappen anders redet. Das mag erstmal faktisch wenig ändern. Das ist ungefähr so ähnlich wie die Beschlüsse des Weißen Hauses. Da werden jetzt nicht alle die Buden gleich zu machen, aber dann hat man erstmal eine Regel, die würde sogar global gelten. Das hielt sich schon für wichtig. Aber man muss die Gegenseite leider sehen. Das ließ sich zum Beispiel in dem FAA-Bericht, also in dem Bericht der Grundrechteaventur. Wir haben halt den Trend in Europa, dass immer mehr Länder gesetzliche Regeln machen. Wir haben in Deutschland eine massive Ausweitung. Und das war auch echt ein Hinweis für die anderen Länder, gar keine Frage. Klar, das wird jetzt verhandelt, aber das wird fünf Jahre später in Karlsruhe verhandelt. Und wir wissen auch noch nicht, was rauskommt. Aber der Trend ist schon andersrum, eindeutig. Ich bin zumindest froh darüber, dass sie sich zu klaren Worten bei Regeln durchgerungen haben. Und der Parlament hat die auch erst mal angenommen. Ich kann mich da komplett anschließen. Ich hätte auch gerne eine UN-Konvention, die sich damit auseinandersetzt.
Genau, kann man ja nur anschließen. Diese UN-Konvention muss natürlich das Ziel sein. Und das kann auch noch zehn Jahre dauern, aber irgendwo muss man anfangen. Eine Sache finde ich noch total wichtig. Ich kenne es auch aus eigenen Gesprächen. Wenn BKA-Leute, wenn man denen sagt, ja, okay, ihr nutzt diese Sachen. Und genau mit den Lücken, die ihr jetzt nutzt und nicht schließt, werden dann halt oppositionell im Iran gefangen, gefördert und ermordet. Dann sagen die halt, ja, es ist halt nicht unsere Aufgabe, die Leute im Iran irgendwie zu schützen. Unsere Aufgabe ist halt, hier Verbrechen aufzuklären. Aber der Witz ist ja, wenn ihr mal auf die oder die Höhrenden mal auf Webseiten gehen von den Wirtschaftsministerien, entweder in den Ländern oder im Bund, da gibt es irgendwo immer so ein gerade ein Projekt Cybersecurity, Cybersicherheit. Ja, Wirtschaftsspionage, wie sie sich schützen können. Und das BSI hat so eine Programme. Und das muss man mal zusammenbringen, dass das eine genau die Kehrseite des anderen ist. Genau deswegen funktioniert der ganze Sicherheitskram nicht so ordentlich. Und genau deswegen kommt diese ganze Wirtschaftsspionage und die Cyber-Sicherheitsprobleme und so weiter. Weil auf der anderen Seite genau diese Lücken ein riesengroßer Markt sind. Und die Sachen zusammenzubringen, das ist glaube ich auch einer der Schritte, um auch irgendwie Mehrheiten zu organisieren. Um da wirklich zu sagen, hier wir müssen es politisch wollen und dann geht es auch. Und wir müssen es wollen, genau deswegen. Es geht nicht nur um die Aktivisten, die irgendwie in Ghana oder so, sondern es geht halt auch irgendwie um den Schraubenhersteller im Schwabenland. Also so leid mir es tut. Teilweise ist das das größere Argument. Das muss man halt auch bedenken.
Es ist halt spannend, ob das sozusagen nicht verstanden wird oder nicht verstanden werden will. Das werden wir wahrscheinlich sozusagen nicht rauskriegen. Du hattest noch eine lange Liste, Elf.
Reiner hat von gesagt, staatliches Hacking dringt so tief in unsere Geräte ein, dass es den Kernbereich privater Lebensgestaltung verletzt und eigentlich grundsätzlich niemals erlaubt sein sollte. Ich bin nicht sicher, dass das eine realistische Forderung ist. Das ist aber ein wichtiger Punkt, der unbedingt immer mit diskutiert werden muss. Mir würde für den Anfang, also nicht reichen, aber es wäre ja schon mal schön, wenn die Behauptungen der Politiker stimmen würden. Wenn Staatstrojaner nämlich wirklich nur zur Verhinderung von Terroranschlägen genutzt würden, wie sie ursprünglich mal eingeführt wurden. Oder meinetwegen heute wirklich nur gegen Terror, Mord und Totschlag. Aber das ist nicht der Fall. Staatstrojaner werden gegen Drogendelikte und wegen der Verleitung zur missbräuchlichen Asylantragstellung eingesetzt. Ich würde fordern, dass jeder Grundrechtseingriff auf Staatstrojaner unbedingt notwendig und verhältnismäßig sein müssen. Das ist bis heute nicht bewiesen. Die Polizei und Geheimdienste behaupten immer, es gäbe ein Going Dark. Nur weil jetzt verschlüsselt wird, werden sie blind und taub. Das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Sie hatten noch nie so viele Daten zur Verfügung wie heute. Und die Aufklärungsquoten von Straftaten gehen die ganze Zeit hoch. Es gibt auch Alternativen zum Staatstrojaner-Einsatz. Es ist nicht immer notwendig und es ist nicht immer verhältnismäßig. Aber selbst wenn es die Fälle gibt, dass in begrenzten Fällen das notwendig und verhältnismäßig ist, hatten wir jetzt schon angesprochen, es sollten keine unbekannten Schwachstellen eingesetzt werden, weil wir uns da selber mehr schaden als nutzen. Es gibt aber auch noch andere Möglichkeiten, Staatstrojaner heimlich auf Geräte zu installieren. Nicht nur komplett unbemerkt, per sogenannten Zero-Click. Das haben wir jetzt gar nicht ausführlich erklärt. Aber es gibt auch jede Menge Staaten, die Hacking-Tools aufspielen, indem sie Fishing machen. Indem sie eine SMS, eine E-Mail, eine andere Nachricht schicken und sagen, hier, klick mal diesen Link. Teilweise unter Mitwirkungspflicht von Mobilfunkanbietern, teilweise, wir haben es im Pegasus-Project gesehen, dass in Spanien Leute, Bürgerinnen eine SMS angeblich von ihrem Sozialamt bekommen haben mit ihrer korrekten Sozialversicherungsnummer und einem korrekten Link, denen gesagt hat, du musst jetzt darauf klicken. Und es sollte verboten sein, dass sich der Staat, dass sich Polizeiaingeheimdienste als andere Institutionen wie auch andere staatliche Stellen ausgeben. Denn wie wollen wir denn Leuten sagen, klickt nicht auf staatliche Links, nutzt Elster oder vertraut in der digitalen Kommunikation mit dem Staat, wenn man davon ausgehen muss, dass staatliche Institutionen diese Möglichkeit zweckentfremden, dass mein Bescheid vom Finanzamt vielleicht in Wirklichkeit ein Staatstreuner ist. Wir schließen uns damit in der Digitalisierung dieser Gesellschaft ins eigene Knie. Also staatliche Stellen sollten sich niemals als irgendjemand anderes ausgeben, sondern immer mit offenem Visier spielen. Staatstreuner sollten immer nur, wenn überhaupt, gegen Einzelpersonen und einzelne Geräte eingesetzt werden und niemals gegen Infrastrukturieren, niemals gegen Server, niemals gegen Netze, niemals gegen Telekommunikationsanbieter. Wir haben heute eine Mitwirkungspflicht im deutschen Gesetz, wo die Deutsche Telekom und ein Internetanbieter verpflichtet sind, auf Anordnung Traffic in deinen Internetverkehr einzuschleusen, damit die Polizei und der Verfassungsschutz einfacher Staatstrojaner installiert werden können. Das ist ein Unding. Wir sollten unsere Internetinfrastruktur in unserer digitalisierten Welt so behandeln, wie das Rote Kreuz oder den Roten Halbmonaten Krisengebieten, dass die immer neutral zu sein haben und dass der Staat die nicht einfach für seine eigenen Zwecke entfremden kann. Und eine ganz wichtige Forderung neben vielen weiteren, die Privacy International, Access, E3 und so noch haben, die mir ganz wichtig ist. Wir leben in einer Welt mit 193 Nationalstaaten, aber einem globalen Internet und jedes Gerät ist nur ein paar Millisekunden auf der Welt entfernt. Staatstrojaner sollten gefälligst niemals über Grenzen eingesetzt werden, ohne dass der Zielstaat zustimmt. Wenn es wirklich nur um Terror und schwerste Kriminalität geht, wie immer behauptet wird, dann ist es doch wohl genauso wie bei einer Telefonenüberwachung oder bei gemeinsamen Strafanmittlungen möglich, im Zielstaat zu sagen, übrigens Polen, das BKA überwacht diesen polnischen Bürger, damit bist du doch wohl einverstanden. Das wollen die aber nicht, weil es denen nicht darum geht. Ihnen geht es nicht um Kriminalität, ihnen geht es um Spionage und Vormachtstellung. Aber wir müssen an dieses Thema ran, Staatstrojaner über Grenzen hinweg, nur mit Zustimmung des Zielstaats. Es sind nicht alle Forderungen. Es gibt noch mehr von Privacy International, Access Now und eDri, die kann ich nur empfehlen.
Das war mir jetzt zu realpolitisch.
Wir haben die auch immer wieder hingeschrieben über die Jahre. Aber ich glaube, was heute eigentlich rauskommen sollte, ist, dass wir nicht reden über morgen, sondern dass wir über die vergangenen Jahre geredet haben und was schon passiert ist. Also mittlerweile ist das nicht mehr... Also das ist ein Abwehrkampf gegen die Realität, wie sie schon ist, weil das ist Teil, was der Pegasus-Ausschuss gezeigt hat, was in dem Pegasus-Project steht und was sozusagen wir jetzt als Realität annehmen müssen. Während wir, als wir vor zehn Jahren darüber geschrieben haben, das immer so gewarnt haben, aber die Zeit ist vorbei. Und was Ilf jetzt vor allen Dingen gesagt hat, ist, geltet das Recht hier. Wir haben diese drei Arten pro Jahr noch definiert. Wir haben den 100A mit einer langen Liste an Straftaten, die auf keinen Fall nur schwerster Kriminalität sind und immer nur den Menschen oder den Staat an sich wirklich bedrohen oder so, sondern das wesentlich tiefer angesetzt. Und die haben noch die Fähigkeit besessen, das in diesem parlamentarischen Schnellverfahren hintenrum einzuschleusen. Da war übrigens in der aktuellen Verfassungsbeschwerde auch noch mal echt angemerkt. Die haben also auch noch unser Parlament dabei verarscht. Das muss man schon so deutlich sagen. Und wir können nur hoffen, dass zumindest ein Teil davon zurückgedreht wird, weil es Signalwirkungen hat. Für mich ist der Unterschied vor allen Dingen, dass es eben bereits ein Kind ist, das im Brunnen gefallen ist, das wir jetzt rauszuholen haben. Und früher war es eher so, ey, macht das mal lieber nicht. Und wir sagen euch, das ist eine Gefahr für die innere Sicherheit und so. Und mittlerweile ist es aber eher wirklich...
Gibt es da momentan gerade so konkrete Daten oder Ansatzpunkte, die mit dem Thema zu tun haben, oder ist das jetzt so eine laufende politische Arbeit?
Na ja, einmal gibt es das Verbausungsbeschwerdeverfahren, wo wir lange gewartet haben, weil diese FTPO-Änderung, die Änderung der Strafprozessordnung, diese unglaubliche Ausweitung ist, die ist von 2018, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Und wir haben jetzt, falls jemand hört, 2023, also jetzt läuft gerade sozusagen die schriftliche Anhörungsphase. Da sind jetzt eine Menge Sachverständigen angefragt, unter anderem wir. Und wir hoffen natürlich, dass sie einen Teil davon zurückdrehen, weil die natürlich auch gegen das geltende Recht hier verstoßen. Aber in der ganzen Zeit ist einfach technisch viel passiert. Das haben wir heute umrissen. Es ist rechtlich viel passiert, es gibt auch rechtliche Urteile. Und diese ganze Branche hat sich sozusagen von so einer kleinen, kleinen, klandestinen Ecke zu einem richtig schön, auch offen färbenden, prosperierenden Markt entwickelt. Und das ist natürlich auch, wenn man die Mechanismen, wenn man in der IT-Sicherheit gegen die Mechanismen des Marktes kämpft, echt schwer, weil diese jetzt seit Jahren bestehende IT-Sicherheitsvertrauenskrise, über die wir jeden Tag lesen können, die besteht ja auch deswegen. Ich habe bemerkt, ich weiß nicht, ob es dir auch befallen ist, in den letzten Jahren erreichen eigentlich nur noch die wirklich krassen, so riesen Ransomware-Angriffe oder wenn mal wieder eine ganze Stadt, mediale Öffentlichkeit, der ganze Kleinscheiß, der passiert, wird nicht mal mehr berichtet. Weil das so ein gravierende Problem ist, das kostet uns alle unendlich Geld. Das hat noch andere Gründe, aber das ist ein Teil der Gründe, besteht darin, dass wir selber diesen ganzen Markt finanzieren. Und vor allen Dingen mit Gründen, die, naja, du musst einfach sehen, damit meine ich, Auftragshacker sind heute sozusagen der Standard. Und das ist auch Wurst, wer denen Geld gibt. Das sind dann halt Auftragshacker. Und wenn du dich als Demokratie entscheidest, da richtig viel Geld reinzustecken, hast du schon irgendwie auch mit Schuld.
Ich würde gern trotzdem noch zwei Ergänzungen machen, auch wenn du das zum Abschluss führen würdest. Konstanz, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wo der Bundestag übergangen wurde. Denn die letzten beiden Änderungen wurden vom Bundestag beschlossen. 2017 hat die Große Koalition, die Abgeordneten, beschlossen, sie wollen es, dass Polizeibehörden immer dann, wenn ein Telefon abgehört werden kann, jetzt auch der Staatstrojaner eingesetzt werden kann, bei alltäglicher Kriminalität. Und 2021 hat dieselbe Große Koalition, die Abgeordneten, noch mal beschlossen, sie wollen das, dass auch die Geheimdienste, alle 19 Geheimdienste, die wir in Deutschland haben, von Bund und Ländern, Staatstrojaner einsetzen können. Das ist nicht nur Sache der Exekutive.
Nee, aber da muss man schon.
Noch eine zweite Ergänzung. Ihr habt jetzt von der Gegenwart geredet und der Vergangenheit. Ich finde das ganz wichtig, den Blick auch noch mal in die Zukunft zu legen. Wir haben relativ viel früher über Laptops und verschlüsselte E-Mails. Und dann irgendwann war es Skype. Und heutzutage ist eigentlich alles nur Smartphones geredet. Da hört es ja aber nicht auf. Wir reden von sämtlichen IT-Geräten. Wir haben Internet-of-shit-Smart-TVs. Wir haben Router. Wir haben Netzwerkinfrastruktur, die gehabt werden kann. Und heutzutage eben medizinische Geräte, Computer, die wir in unseren Körper pflanzen. Und fahrende Autos und fliegende Flugzeuge, die heutzutage Computer sitzen, in die wir unsere Körper setzen. Und all das kann von Staaten gehackt werden. Und dafür gibt es kommerzielle Software. Und dazu gibt es auch staatliche Institutionen, wie die CITES die explizit daran hackt, Autos zu hacken. Also wir sollten auch ein bisschen davon wegkommen, als ob es nur um Messenger und nur um Smartphones geht.
Jetzt musst du kurz CITES erklären.
CITES ist die zentrale Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich. Eine ohne Gesetz gegründete Behörde in München, die den Auftrag hat, Polizei- und Geheimdienste mit Informationstechnik IT, also Hard- und Software und Tools, zur unter anderem Überwachung, Analyse, Forensik zu unterstützen.
Und interessant ist, der Chef ist ein Expeiendäler und die sitzen auf dem Campus der Bundeswehr. Nur zu dem zivilen Kontext dieser Agentur. Ich wollte noch mal kurz reagieren auf diese 2018 Beschlossene vom Bundestag.
Leute!
Nee, nee, nee, Moment, das ist nämlich total wichtig, weil das war nicht eine ewig lange Diskussion, wo das deliberativ in einem demokratischen Prozess, sondern das Format, was sie gewählt haben, war die sogenannte Formulierungshilfe. Das ist eine Möglichkeit, wie man bei einem Gesetz, kurz bevor es abgestimmt wird, dann noch mal einen Punkt reinsetzen kann oder einen Komma oder da vielleicht noch einen erklärenden Satz mit reinmachen. Formulierungshilfe heißt das. Und da wurde dann dieser 100 A mit reingeschrieben, das können wir noch machen. Also das war, egal wie man irgendwie zu dem Bundestrojaner oder irgendwas steht, ist das aus demokratischer Prozesssicht ein absolutes No-Go. Das ist, glaube ich, auch noch mal ein Punkt, wo man...
Mein Punkt bleibt, die Abgeordneten von CDU, CSU und SPD wollten, dass sie haben mit ihrer Stimme genau dafür gestimmt. Es war ihnen bekannt und sie wollten das bewusst.
Wir haben noch keine Daten. Also jetzt im Sommer endet sozusagen ein schriftlicher Anhörungsverfahren. Und die Stellungnahmen werden eingeholt. Also alle Sachverständigen wissen immer, wie die anderen Sachverständigen heißen, aber wir wissen jetzt sozusagen nicht, wie es nach dem Juli weitergeht. Aber man kann davon ausgehen, dass sie sicherlich im Herbst noch mal eine Anhörung machen. Und man kann natürlich davon ausgehen, dass es ein Urteil geben wird, sonst würden sie sich damit nicht so intensiv beschäftigen. Also sie weisen in der Regel keine Verfassungsbeschwerde ab, mit der sie sich so intensiv auseinandersetzen. Und natürlich, man kriegt die Erzsachverständige zugeschickt und die ist meiner Meinung nach auch überhaupt öffentlich verfügbar. Sie zeigt natürlich sehr deutlich, ja, in welcher Weise die geltende Gesetzgebung, also jetzt in diesem konkreten Fall die Strafprozessordnung rechtswidrig ist. Also die pokern schon sehr auch in den Schwächen des Gesetzes.
Okay, also heißt dieses Jahr noch, gibt es vielleicht Neuigkeiten?
Ja, aber also weiß man jetzt nicht, wie lange es dauert, bis ein Urteil kommt. Wahrscheinlich ein Urteil dann als nächstes Jahr. Aber wenn sie eine Anhörung machen, dann wahrscheinlich dieses Jahr. Aber man kann ja beim K2-Erricht nie genau wissen. Ich finde aber wichtig, dass sie es tun. Und wir alle müssen dafür sorgen, dass das eine Öffentlichkeit hat. Und wenn wir darüber nicht mehr debattieren, und mir scheint, das ist ein Non-Thema, das zeigt dieser Pegasus-Ausschuss. Ja, das ist ein Skandal, den einige EU-Politiker als mit Watergate verglichen haben. Aber das reicht auf keinen Fall medial daran. In manchen Ländern Europas ist es so gut wie überhaupt nicht berichtet worden. Aber betreffend tut es natürlich alle. Insofern, wir müssen daran mitwirken.
Aber wir haben heute hier einen kleinen Unterschied gemacht. Ilf, Rainer, Konz, ich danke euch, dass ihr da wart. Ich finde es sehr spannend, euch geduldig bemüht habt, das komplexe Thema in kurzer Zeit mal aufzurollen. Ich hoffe, das hat ein bisschen funktioniert.
Ja, danke dir, dass du das Chaos versucht hast zu beherrschen.
Ich stelle dir nur Fragen. Liebe HörerInnen, ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen. Schreibt uns gerne in die Kommentare, falls ihr noch Fragen habt. Ansonsten bleibt mir noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.